yeah welcome to this video planes mr.
master is oh cool what is it L so cool
and I really cannot tell them apart here
let's see what we get maybe a Catalan
opening or something
I know Queen's Indian style setup
okay know which has posted their joke
I have fun I play the speed three line
let's see what he's doing if he can't
play the high of transporting you have
to a ready to start setup
most players I go for D six or a six
staying within the typical on Hedgehog
setups this is now a red team and I
think I could have taken on D 596 so
maybe it slightly inaccurate I think I
should have taken on d5 but okay it's
not like decisive actor
and yeah I didn't really want that
not that I'm sure that's this bad or
anything don't really know okay maybe
this isn't a big deal yeah it's um it's
it's right here but I know I'm not sure
that this really has mentioned a problem
but just take you take him and click we
need five you know this should be okay
this this Paul on these three is also a
bit term on its own and can also be a
liability but okay of course this is not
the way to to play with white if you
want an an advantage yeah I need to take
on d5 instead of Queenie two
forgot forgot about that
so where where do you go now maybe maybe
23 it's not a bad square 4 yeah probably
therefore hmm interesting
interesting 34 would be wit now like
with reform and but probably he just
wants to play night see - at some stage
and activate his his rook sir okay
forego hmm if I go III now evil play
Nazi - we are takes takes sure it's
probably not great for what
hmmm how to fight in this position is as
possible I'm thinking about ideas like
if he goes so c2 playing 95 and just
activating pieces
okay just do that let's see to us the
only move now
otherwise the plane 95 okay
it's a always amazing that okay maybe he
can play that and look look strange to
me but maybe he can play it night see
two would have sacrificed a point for
lots of activity
yeah 13 Knight f6 and now it spawns are
just weak the night here is not doing so
much it can play 90 forward not sure if
he will manage
Casey sacrificing exchange now and I def
6
yeah yeah probably should do that
what now right a to eyes got III awesome
this is it looks very passive
yeah this is always very nice it's just
like you coincidence you can play all
that okay so on let's still see what
what you can do here
yeah we'll get the porn at least really
yeah didn't understand any office moves
probably should just play
and so come on here this must be winning
I have all I go away I go completely
insane here time warning check check
check
check check check check
check check check
check
check-check
okay yeah very much - a long time yeah I
wasn't sure I mean did the Queen trade
here maybe not it meant it is just
winning everything wins but just a
matter of doing it Indian I shot manager
in 11 seconds okay I'm a bit rusty after
two weeks not playing any getting chess
yeah
never can you say was just playing on
time the whole game basically like like
here didn't understand anything of this
why not exchange play 95 or whatever you
can play just much better why this is
just obviously bad I'm much much more
active in comparison but he was playing
on time the whole the whole game
basically 110 yeah yeah this is this is
winning but okay 25 seconds didn't
didn't manage at the end at least the
draw okay thanks for watching